a former Texas police officer could
spend the rest of his life in prison
after being convicted of murder for the
killing of an unarmed black teenager the
conviction of former bolts Springs
officer Roy Oliver yesterday is a rare
guilty verdict in a police shooting case
he shot and killed fifteen year old
Jordan Edwards in April 2017
Omar Villafranca is in Dallas where the
jury is deciding the sentence now Omar
good morning good morning Oliver is only
the second officer in a decade to be
convicted of murder into police shooting
and when that verdict came down people
in the courtroom including the Edwards
family could barely contain their
emotions we did it we did a visibly
emotional Odell Edwards held back tears
the father of fifteen year old Jordan
Edwards overwhelmed by the verdict we
the jury unanimously find the defendant
guilty of murder after nearly two weeks
of testimony a jury convicted former
Balch Springs police officer Roy Oliver
of killing the unarmed teen body camera
video from the night of the shooting
shows Oliver and his partner responding
to a loud house party Oliver told the
investigators he heard gunshots
saw a car headed towards his partner and
feared for his partner's life then fired
five shots into the vehicle hitting
Edwards in the head and killing him but
the body cam video showed the car
driving away from the officers and
Oliver's former partner testified that
he never felt he was in danger I'm gonna
tell you right now those jurors are
courageous jasmine Crockett is an
attorney for the Edwards family it was a
guilty on murder not manslaughter not
some lesser included but on murder it so
many times that you see on the TV that
this has happened and nothing ever
happens during Oliver's sentencing
hearing Edwards stepmother Charmaine
spoke directly to the jury ever grateful
[ __ ] I'll sing your heart to see that
it was wrong because once I mean it
doesn't bring Jordan back
we have some kind of closure Oliver
sentencing hearing will continue later
on this morning he could spend life in
prison Nora
Wright Omar thank you